افاد مراسل الجزيره بتواصل الاشتباكات في
عده محاور من مخيمي طول كارم ونور شمس على
وقع العمليه العسكريه التي لا تزال مستمره
منذ ساعات وكانت القوات الاسرائيليه قد
اعلنت مخيم نور شمس في طولكرم منطقه
عسكريه مغلقه وفرضت حظر التجوال فيه جاء
ذلك بعد ان اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال او قوات
كبيره من جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مصحوبه
بعدد من الجرافات مدينه طول كرم من محورها
الغربي الجنوبي وافاد الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني بان طواقمه اسعفت ثلاثه من
مواطنين اصيبوا نتيجه اعتداء جنود
الاحتلال عليهم
بالضرب ينضم الينا من طول كارم مراسل
الجزيره ليث جعار ليث اخر التطورات
لديك
بالفعل العمليه العسكريه لجيش الاحتلال لا
تزال متواصله حتى هذه اللحظه في مخيمي نور
شمس وطول كرم على وقع الاشتباكات المسلحه
التي لا تزال متواصله والانفجارات بين
الفينه والاخرى هنا من امام مخيم نور شمس
حيث نرصد في هذه الصوره تواجد لاليات
الاحتلال العسكريه التي لا تزال متواصله
في حصارها لمخيم نور شمس بالتزامن مع ذلك
هناك انفجارات تسمع قبل او سمعت قبل قليل
في مخيم طول كرم حيث لا تزال الاشتباكات
تتواصل في عده احياء من المخيم على واقع
الحصار الذي ايضا يفرضه الاحتلال على
المخيم هنا في في نور شمس وفي هذه الصوره
ربما التي تشاهدونها على الهواء مباشره هو
موقع حوله الاحتلال هو يعني مركز تجاري
حوله الاحتلال الى ثكنه عسكريه
ونقطه نقطه
لتحقيق الميداني في هذه المنطقه حيث لا
تزال لا يزال الاحتلال ينفذ حملات مداهمه
واسعه داخل المخيم ويعتقل عدد واعتقل عدد
من الفلسطينيين في اطار العمليه العسكريه
المتواصله هنا في هذه المنطقه يتم التحقيق
ميدانيا مع من يتم اعتقالهم من المواطنين
الفلسطينيين من داخل مخيمي الكرم ونور شمس
حيث لا تزال اليات الاحتلال تطبق الخناق
فعليا على مخيم نور شمس لاكثر من تسعه
ساعات على بدء هذه العملي العسكريه قبل
قليل كان هناك انسحاب لبعض الاليات
العسكريه واعاده تموضع من جديد
وبالتزامن مع وصول تعزيزات اخرى الى محيط
هذا المخيم ويعني لا تزال كما اسلفنا
العمليه العسكريه متواصله والانتشار
متواصل هنا في منطقه وسط المخيم التي تظهر
في هذه الصوره حيث الاشتباكات والانفجارات
منذ ساعه الليل وهي تسمع ولم يعني تهدا
حتى هذه اللحظه بين الفينه والاخرى هناك
استهداف لاليات الاحتلال العسكريه في هذه
المنطقه الى الاعلى من هذه من وسط المخيم
من منطقه جبل الصالحين وجبل النصر الذي
ايه
قامت او قام الجنود الراجلين باقتحامه ومن
ثم البدء باقتحام المنازل من هذه المنطقه
الى الجنوب من مخيم نور شمس ايضا هناك
لربما المصور يرصد التواجد للاليات
العسكريه في منطقه جبل النصر في هذه
اللحظات حيث تواجد للاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في المنطقه منذ ساعات الليل
وحتى هذه اللحظه لا تزال متواصله في في
انحاء متفرقه من هذه المنطقه ايضا على
يعني الطريق الرئيس هناك تواجد لاليات
الاحتلال العسكريه التي لا تزال متواصله
حتى هذه اللحظه وتقوم ب يعني بين الفينه
والاخرى بالتحرك واعاده التموضع على
الطريق الرئيسي لمخيم نور شمس هذا المخيم
الذي يشهد منذ ايه اشهر عده ايه اقتحامات
متواصله ارتفعت وتيرتها منذ السابع من
اكتوبر الماضي حيث ايه يعني في كل يوم
تقريبا هناك اقتحام لهذا المخيم منذ
اسبوعين فقط تم رصد ما يزيد عن اربعه
اقتحامات لهذا المخيم
ويعني ادى ذلك لاستشهاد عدد من
الفلسطينيين فيما اعتقل الاحتلال عدد اخر
من هؤلاء واصيب عدد تم نقلهم الى
المستشفيات وحتى هذه اللحظه لا تزال
العمليه العسكريه والعمليات العسكريه في
مدينه طول كرم وفي مدن الضفه الغربيه
المحتله متواصله شكرا نعم ليث جعار مراسل
الجزيره كنت معنا من طول كرم شكرا جزيلا
لك